So now we're going to touch on some material that we talked about during the
lesson on the brain which was lesson three. This material may feel pretty
dense, but you can always refer to the document we're giving you on the
physiological side of the stress response. Stressful events can cause changes
in our physiology. Most importantly, we see that the autonomic nervous system,
endocrine system and the brain all interact together to produce changes in our
body systems as a result of stress. Remember that the autonomic nervous system
has both the sympathetic and parasympathetic nervous systems. Sympathetic is
responsible for arousing and parasympathetic is responsible for calming.
Remember, for example, when Susan encountered the bear in Yosemite? This
resulted in activation of her sympathetic nervous system, which allowed for an
increase in heart rate, which pumped more blood to the large muscle groups, and
more oxygen was available so her muscles can function and react to the
dangerous situation she found herself in. In addition to the autonomic system,
the endocrine system is important in our stress response because it consists of
the major hormone-releasing glands that are active during our stress response.
That's the Pituitary gland and the Adrenal glands.